all right as we told you Fort Myers
everybody knows Fort Myers took a direct
hit as hurricane Ian came ashore here is
what that looks like in terms of storm
surge it is startling how quickly entire
communities can be submerged Manuel
bojorquez rode out the night in Fort
Myers he's there for us now Manny good
morning how are you
Nora good morning even without being
able to drive around this area because
there are downed trees everywhere and
likely standing water we can see that
there's Devastation here this is the
hotel where we rode out the storm and
this debris here was left by the storm
surge there's pieces of wood over there
there's some lounge chairs a picnic
table a bridge over here this was stuff
that was over that way the Gulf of
Mexico 200 yards away but all of this
was underwater just about 24 hours ago I
can tell you from just trying to peer
out at the height of the storm that the
winds and the storm surge were the
highest that I've ever experienced
covering any of the hurricanes and and
the problem here is it just lingered for
so long it was hours upon hours upon
hours of just the worst parts of the
hurricane the priority today of course
will not only be assessing the damage
but trying to rescue anybody who was
caught in an area that is now how
inaccessible or flooded Nora
oh Manny I'm glad to see you are okay
and thinking about all those residents
including many retirees that live in
that Fort Myers area thank you so much